Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Écrire, ça demande une grande concentration.
Moi, je perds le fil quand j’entends mon
chien boire — alors imaginez écrire en
pleine guerre !
Hegel, lui, écrit au son des canons de l’armée
napoléonienne qui approchent de Iéna,
la ville du centre de l’Allemagne où Hegel
donne des cours privés à l’université.
Il achève son livre in extremis : il met
un point final la nuit qui précède la bataille.
Mais voilà, l’armée de Napoléon ravage
la ville.
Des soldats pillent le logement de Hegel.
Menacé par ces hommes, le philosophe trouve
refuge chez des amis.
Il a tout laissé derrière lui.
Dans ses poches, il y a les pages du livre
qu’il a fini d’écrire au dernier moment.
Ce livre sauvé des combats et des incendies,
c’est la Phénoménologie de l’esprit.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler de Hegel ?
Vous avez déjà essayé de le lire ?
Hegel passe pour le philosophe le plus difficile
à comprendre.
C’est simplement impossible, pour un étudiant,
de découvrir la pensée de Hegel en s'attaquant
directement au texte.
Hegel a la réputation d’être un universitaire
très abstrait — pour parler gentiment.
Il passe aussi pour un homme ultra rigoureux,
obsédé par les règles.
Il ne connaîtrait que la vie des idées parce
qu’il aurait passé la sienne dans les livres.
Mais tout ça, c’est la légende.
Hegel a en réalité eu une vie très mouvementée
et très intéressante.
Et ce que j’ai découvert en lisant ces
biographies, c’est que toute une partie
de cette vie est restée cachée pendant bien
longtemps.
Vous voulez connaître la vérité sur Hegel
?
Et sans vous prendre la tête, bien sûr ?
Alors écoutez-moi jusqu’au bout.
Nous sommes dans les années 1770.
À seulement 5 ans, Hegel entre à ce qu’on
appelle l’« École latine ».
Le latin était encore la langue de l’éducation
et de l’érudition en Occident.
Et quand Hegel entre dans cette « École
latine », il connaît déjà la première
déclinaison du latin (celle des mots qui
se terminent en -a).
Il sait déjà du latin à 5 ans ?!
Eh bien oui, c’est pas un mythe.
Et il y a une explication simple : c’est
SA MÈRE qui l’a initié au latin à la
maison.
Les grands penseurs sont souvent le fruit
d’une stimulation précoce, et Hegel ne
fait pas exception.
Sa mère est une femme cultivée qui se soucie
beaucoup de l’avenir de son fils.
C’est rare, à l’époque, qu’une mère
de famille ait reçu une éducation assez
poussée pour être capable de faire le prof
pour ses enfants.
C’est vrai pour la mère de Hegel comme
ça l’avait déjà été pour celle de Kant.
Ça montre que le savoir était vraiment valorisé
chez les Hegel.
C’est en partie dû à leur milieu.
La famille de Hegel appartient à la bourgeoisie
intellectuelle :
le père a étudié le droit à l’université
et il occupe un poste dans l’administration
judiciaire.
Et puis la mère est la fille d’un avocat.
Elle aime les livres, et c’est clairement
elle qui transmet à Hegel l’amour du savoir.
Mais elle meurt lors d’une épidémie de
dysenterie lorsque Hegel a 11 ans.
Après, le père est sur la même longueur
d’ondes.
Par exemple, il paie à Hegel des cours particuliers
de maths et de français alors même que la
famille n’est pas riche.
En France, on a ce qu’on appelle la « classe
préparatoire ».
C’est l’étape la plus difficile du parcours
d’une partie de l’élite scolaire de la
nation.
Les étudiants passent 2 ou 3 ans à préparer
les concours de ce que le système français
appelle les « Grandes Écoles ».
Ils ressortent souvent transformés de ces
2-3 années de préparation parce qu’ils
ont abattu un gros volume de travail intellectuel
dans un contexte d’urgence et de concurrence.
Eh bien Hegel fait un peu la prépa de l’époque,
en Allemagne.
Sauf que pour lui, c’est 5 ans !
À 18 ans, il entre au séminaire luthérien
de Tübingen,
dans le duché de Wurtemberg, au sud de l’Allemagne
(à 50km au sud de Stuttgart).
Un séminaire luthérien, ça forme des étudiants
à la théologie protestante luthérienne.
Et le débouché naturel de cette formation,
c’est pasteur
(c’est-à-dire le guide de la communauté
religieuse protestante),
ou bien prof de théologie.
Le séminaire de Tübingen est particulièrement
réputé.
Comme Hegel est premier de sa classe au lycée
de Stuttgart, il obtient une bourse pour le
séminaire de Tübingen.
Il y aura un mode de vie comparable à celui
d’un élève de prépa en France :
travail intellectuel intense, notamment en
théologie ;
surmenage et concurrence scolaire.
Mais il y a en plus une stricte discipline
religieuse.
Il faut se soumettre à divers rituels religieux,
et les livres qui ne sont pas conformes à
la ligne religieuse officielle sont interdits
(les étudiants lisent Kant et Rousseau en
cachette, par exemple).
Ces conditions difficiles rapprochent Hegel
de deux autres étudiants avec lesquels il
partage sa chambre, et qui deviendront eux
aussi des grands noms de la culture allemande
:
le poète Hölderlin et philosophe Schelling.
Les trois génies en herbe — Hegel, Hölderlin
et Schelling — partagent également la même
curiosité et le même rejet du conditionnement
intellectuel du séminaire.
Ils se stimulent mutuellement.
Étant donné la logique du désir, plus les
profs et l’administration interdisent les
idées originales, plus les élèves s’y
intéressent.
Au point que Hegel et ses deux amis deviennent
fan de la Révolution française, qui se produit
au milieu de leur scolarité.
Ils fêtent l’événement.
Et une légende dit même que Hegel et Hölderlin
assistent à la plantation d’un arbre de
la liberté sur le marché de Tübingen
— ce qui est un acte politique assez risqué
à l’époque.
Bref, les trois amis détestent l’atmosphère
idéologique du séminaire.
Du coup, ils refusent leur destin tout tracé
: ils ne seront ni pasteurs ni théologiens.
Mais si Hegel ne veut être ni pasteur ni
théologien, il va faire quoi ?
Contrairement à Descartes, qui disposait
de plusieurs domestiques, ou contrairement
plus tard à Schopenhauer, qui a hérité
de son père
— contrairement à eux, Hegel n’est pas
rentier, donc il faut bien qu’il trouve
un moyen de gagner sa vie.
Eh bien à l’époque, il n’y a pas mille
solutions :
quand on a l’érudition de Hegel et qu’on
ne sait rien faire d’autre, on devient précepteur,
c’est-à-dire prof particulier permanent.
Kant a été placé dans la même situation.
Hegel et ses deux amis, Hölderlin et Schelling,
acceptent tous les trois des positions dans
des familles nobles ou riches.
À leurs yeux, c’est moins difficile et
moins humiliant qu’un emploi religieux.
Mais à l’époque, précepteur, c’est
vraiment pas le top.
En fait, c’est le même niveau qu’un domestique.
Le précepteur est complètement soumis à
ses employeurs, et il subit souvent leur mépris.
C’est d’autant plus difficile pour des
jeunes fraîchement sortis du prestigieux
séminaire de Tübingen qu’ils ont conscience
de leur supériorité intellectuelle.
Le poète Hölderlin — un de le bande des
trois avec Hegel et Schelling —
Hölderlin s'enfuit à plusieurs reprises
de sa place de précepteur
(une fois, c’est parce qu’il a une relation
avec la femme de son maître).
Hegel, lui, n’est pas si mal traité.
Il fait d’abord 3 ans dans une famille aristocratique
de Berne, l’actuelle capitale de la Suisse.
Il a sa propre chambre ; les maîtres l'admettent
parfois à la table familiale ;
et en plus, ils lui laissent du temps libre
pour poursuivre ses propres études.
D’un côté, c’est pour lui une riche
expérience sociale.
C’est un poste d’observation pour comprendre
l’élite sociale et le système politique
suisses.
Hegel parvient également à s'introduire
auprès de personnages intéressants dans
les mondanités suisses.
Mais de l’autre côté, il souffre de son
isolement intellectuel et il a le sentiment
de perdre sa jeunesse.
Après Berne, il fera encore 3 années à
Francfort, au centre de l’Allemagne.
Cette expérience de précepteur n’est pas
anodine dans le destin de Hegel.
En effet, les précepteurs sont le vivier
de l’élite intellectuelle allemande de
l’époque (essentiellement les profs et
les écrivains).
Ils sont statistiquement une infime minorité
de la population, mais ils sont des personnages
importants dans beaucoup de romans et de pièces
de théâtre, tout simplement parce que les
auteurs puisent dans leur vécu.
On peut imaginer que c’est son expérience
de précepteur qui a inspiré à Hegel sa
fameuse dialectique du maître et de l’esclave.
Elle a probablement aussi renforcé sa conscience
politique libérale.
Nous sommes en octobre 1808.
Hegel a 38 ans.
Il vient de recevoir un blâme du gouvernement
bavarois.
Qu’est-ce qu’il a fait pour mériter ce
blâme ?
Il a dévoilé des informations concernant
la rencontre entre l’empereur Napoléon
et le tsar Alexandre Ier de Russie ALORS MÊME
qu’elle n’est pas terminée.
Le gouvernement bavarois somme Hegel de dévoiler
ses sources.
Il refuse.
Mais attendez…
pourquoi est-ce que Hegel diffuse des informations
concernant une rencontre diplomatique ?
Eh bien parce qu’à l’époque il est journaliste.
Et parce que Hegel fait bien son travail.
Toujours.
Un an plus tôt, il a fui Iéna ravagée par
l’armée napoléonienne.
Il se retrouve à 36 ans à Bamberg, à 200km
au sud de Iéna.
Pourquoi cette ville ? Parce qu’un ami lui
a déniché un poste dans un journal local.
Hegel est journaliste de mars 1807 à novembre
1808, et il travaille avec probité, zèle
et esprit critique.
Non seulement il cherche les meilleures informations
et il s’efforce de les communiquer de manière
vivante, mais il s’intéresse aussi aux
détails techniques.
Il cherche un papier de meilleure qualité
; il fait en sorte que les caractères d’imprimerie
soient plus nets.
Mais voilà, il se rend compte à quel point
la presse c’est compliqué.
Moi j’ai fait un stage dans un grand journal
français il y a 10 ans, et je me souviens
que mon maître de stage m’avait dit dès
les premiers jours : « Surtout ne deviens
pas journaliste ».
À l’époque de Hegel, c’était déjà
financièrement difficile — mais en plus
il y avait une censure étouffante.
Hegel en est victime — et quand il tient
tête au gouvernement bavarois qui veut ses
sources, c’est parce qu’il sait déjà
qu’il va quitter le journal.
Son ami — toujours le même — lui a décroché
un poste de proviseur de lycée à Nuremberg,
à 60km au sud de Bamberg.
Là, il n’est pas embêté par les autorités,
mais c’est quand même la galère.
Les bâtiments du lycée sont vétustes, sous-équipés,
et il n’y a même pas de toilettes fonctionnels
(Hegel doit trouver lui-même une solution
!).
Il n’y a pas d’argent ni d’administration
digne de ce nom.
Le chaos ambiant ne favorise pas la discipline
des élèves, qui fument et se battent en
duel dans le lycée.
Hegel lui-même est logé dans un appartement
vétuste,
et il ne reçoit son salaire qu'irrégulièrement
à cause de l'anarchie qui règne en Bavière.
Mais bon, il fait face ; il fait du mieux
qu’il peut avec ce qu’il a.
Et d’après les témoignages, la situation
du lycée s’améliore progressivement.
Cette anecdote montre que contrairement à
ce que l’abstraction de la philosophie de
Hegel nous laisse imaginer, il n’a pas passé
sa vie à l’université et dans les bibliothèques.
Il a une certaine expérience concrète, et
pas des moindres.
Cela montre aussi que le succès intellectuel
de Hegel est tardif.
Il a presque 40 ans et il n’est même pas
prof d’université.
Je vous l’ai dit, lorsque Hegel est proviseur,
c’est une période difficile.
Mais tout n’est pas sombre dans le tableau.
En effet, Hegel a trouvé une fiancée, la
jeune, belle et noble Maria (qui a 20 ans
de moins que lui).
Avec elle, il pense pouvoir trouver le bonheur
conjugal.
Donc la veille de la cérémonie de mariage,
il est confiant en l’avenir.
Sauf qu’il y a un souci, et pas des moindres
: il n’a pas l’argent pour la cérémonie
!
On lui doit toujours 5 mois de salaire, et
il va devoir annuler sa cérémonie de mariage
s’il ne les reçoit pas d’ici peu !
Mais même s’il reçoit son salaire en temps
et en heure, cela ne changera rien à sa situation
: Hegel est pauvre.
Du coup, le père de sa future femme était
réticent.
Il a d’abord conditionné son accord à
l’obtention d’un poste à l’université
par Hegel.
Mais étant donné que lui non plus n’avait
pas un rond, il n’a pas pu imposer sa condition.
Et puis Hegel est quand même proviseur, avec
un potentiel avéré de philosophe, ce qui
lui confère un certain prestige social.
La misère des universités due à la guerre
a retardé le destin de Hegel.
Sa pauvreté est même une des causes de l’obscurité
de son style.
Une fois marié, ses besoins financiers sont
plus élevés.
Donc il écrit à la hâte le livre dont il
espère qu’il sera son chef-d’œuvre,
la Science de la logique.
Il y en a pour plus de 1200 pages dans les
éditions modernes !
Il faut certainement une année à temps plein
au moins, ou plusieurs années, pour arriver
au bout d’un travail aussi colossal — sans
parler de la complexité du propos —
mais Hegel écrit le livre dans la précipitation
au cours des six premiers mois de son mariage.
Ça ne rend pas les soirées des jeunes mariés
très amusantes.
Mais « j’ai besoin d’argent pour vivre
», confesse Hegel.
Et puis un ouvrage fondamental de philosophie
comme la Science de la logique, ça va augmenter
ses chances de décrocher un poste à l’université.
Il y parviendra 5 ans plus tard, c’est-à-dire
à 45 ans,
à l’université de Heidelberg, à 200km
à l’ouest de Nuremberg.
Il sera enfin reconnu comme philosophe au
sens culturel et administratif.
Son salaire donnera enfin une base économique
solide à sa vie de famille.
Mais sa longue pauvreté ne sera pas anodine.
Même prof à l’université, Hegel est bien
loin de ce qu’on appelle aujourd’hui la
« Fuck you money », c’est-à-dire un niveau
de richesse qui assurerait une totale liberté
de parole.
Hegel, lui, ne peut pas dire n’importe quoi,
car il a une famille à nourrir.
Donc il est prudent.
C’est un point qui fait débat, mais je
pense que la pauvreté et la dépendance de
Hegel sont le facteur principal de l’obscurité
de ses textes philosophiques.
En effet, cette obscurité rend Hegel inclassable
:
il n’est jamais ouvertement contestataire
(sinon il finit en prison) ;
et il n’est pas non plus explicitement réactionnaire.
L’adolescent qui commet un vol, c’est
un classique auquel beaucoup de parents sont
confrontés.
En plus, le fils de Hegel a volé une somme
dérisoire — probablement l’équivalent
de 5 ou 10 euros aujourd’hui.
Mais le père monte sur ses grands chevaux
: il fait retirer à son fils son patronyme.
Il n’est plus digne de s’appeler « Hegel
» !
En fait, le vol n’est pas la raison du retrait
du patronyme — c’est le prétexte.
Et pourquoi cette sanction ?
Parce que ce fils, qui s’appelle Louis,
est gênant depuis bien longtemps.
Ce n’est pas l’enfant de Madame Hegel
— c’est un enfant ANTÉRIEUR au mariage,
et dont la mère était la logeuse de Hegel
à Iéna.
Louis est ce qu’on appelle à l’époque
un « fils naturel », c’est-à-dire un
fils né hors mariage
(lorsque Hegel avait 37 ans).
Apparemment, sa mère était vraiment amoureuse
de Hegel.
Il semble qu’il lui ait promis le mariage,
et il semble qu’elle l’ait empêché de
retrouver une femme
— en vain, comme je vous l’ai dit.
Mais Louis, lui, est resté dans la vie de
Hegel.
Et il cause les plus grands soucis à son
père à partir de son mariage.
Il l’empêche de vivre normalement.
Hegel a pourtant obtenu de sa femme qu’elle
accepte d’intégrer Louis dans la famille.
Il lui a fait suivre la même scolarité que
ses autres enfants, au lycée français de
Berlin.
Mais Louis est malheureux partout.
La relation père-fils est tendue.
Les malentendus et les conflits se multiplient.
Malgré leurs tentatives de réconciliation,
Hegel et Louis se blessent souvent l’un
l’autre.
Le père réprime, supplie ; le fils fugue.
Le vol est la goutte qui fait déborder le
vase : Louis ne s’appellera plus « Hegel
».
C’est terrible, parce que ça signifie que
le père renie, désormais, le fils qu’il
avait pourtant reconnu, et dont il avait véritablement
pris soin.
La fin de l’histoire est tragique.
Hegel achète à son fils — qui a alors
18 ans — une charge d'officier dans l'armée
coloniale hollandaise.
Louis quitte donc la famille pour le service
de la Hollande.
Il ne donne pas de nouvelles pendant 5 ans,
et il meurt aux Indes à 24 ans.
Les partisans et les deux fils légitimes
de Hegel taisent l’existence de Louis pour
diverses raisons.
À l’époque, un fils naturel est une honte,
et donc les adversaires de Hegel pourraient
se servir de cette information.
Et puis, cela colle mal avec la réputation
de Hegel, qui défend le respect des règles
dans tous les domaines.
Donc l’existence de Louis Hegel — nous
on peut lui rendre son nom de famille
— l’existence de Louis Hegel restera un
secret jusqu’à plus de 60 ans après la
mort du philosophe.
Je ne sais pas si vous souvenez de l’ami
grâce auquel Hegel a obtenu un poste de journaliste,
puis le poste de proviseur de lycée.
Cet ami, c’est Niethammer, que Hegel a fréquenté
au séminaire de Tübingen.
Pour avoir sorti Hegel de la panade déjà
deux fois — en lui trouvant les emplois
de journaliste et de proviseur
— rien que ces faveurs font de Niethammer
un super ami.
Mais ça ne s’arrête pas là !
C’est encore Niethammer qui a trouvé la
femme de Hegel.
Et c’est grâce à ses conseils et son influence
que le mariage se fait, en dépit de la pauvreté
de Hegel et de son fils naturel.
Alors, si on considère uniquement cette amitié,
on se dit simplement que Hegel a un super
ami qui fait un peu office d’ange gardien.
Sauf que cet ami n’est pas le seul à aider
Hegel.
Ce qui est assez étonnant, c’est qu’à
de nombreuses reprises — systématiquement,
en fait — Hegel reçoit de l’aide lorsqu’il
est dans le besoin.
Il a besoin d’un emploi ? On lui trouve
un emploi.
Il a besoin d’argent ? On lui en prête,
voire on lui donne.
Il a besoin de placer son fils naturel ? On
s’en occupe.
Il veut se marier ? On lui trouve une femme.
Il veut donner des cours à l’université
? Il bâcle une petite thèse et le jury lui
accorde le titre de docteur.
Bref, l’impression qu’on a en considérant
le parcours de Hegel, c’est qu’il est
au centre d’un PUISSANT réseau d’entraide.
Et ce réseau, c’est la franc-maçonnerie.
Je cite ce livre pour vous montrer que je
ne délire pas :
« le biographe se lasse presque de retrouver
tant de francs-maçons autour du philosophe
».
Ce n’est pas étonnant, parce que la franc-maçonnerie
de l’époque — même si elle regroupe
une diversité d’orientations idéologiques
— la franc-maçonnerie de l’époque est
en partie un grand réseau d’intellectuels
progressistes.
Il est donc naturel pour un partisan des idées
des Lumières, un fan de la Révolution française
comme Hegel, d’être maçon.
Or, les franc-maçons se considèrent comme
des frères.
Ils sont tenus, au sein de chaque loge, par
un devoir d’assistance mutuelle.
Ça sera bien utile à Hegel, dont le savoir
est la seule ressource.
En effet, il intègre assez tôt la société
secrète, lors de sa première mission de
précepteur en Suisse.
Pour sa seconde mission de précepteur, il
officie chez les Gogel, une famille de négociants
extrêmement riche très impliquée dans la
franc-maçonnerie.
Les Gogel ont même joué un rôle important
dans une autre organisation secrète, les
« Illuminés de Bavière », qui sont à
l’origine de la légende moderne des Illuminati.
Cette société secrète a été dissoute
pendant l’adolescence de Hegel, mais la
fraternité entre ses membres perdure.
Apparemment, Hegel est au courant.
Donc pour persuader les Gogel de le prendre
comme précepteur, il leur écrit un poème
intitulé Éleusis qui reprend des thèmes
et des symboles des « Illuminés de Bavière
».
Ce poème est une profession de foi.
C’est une manière de dire aux Gogel qu’il
appartient DÉJÀ à leur famille.
Nous sommes dans les années 1820.
Hegel est un des pontes de l’Université
de Berlin, qui est alors la plus riche et
la plus prestigieuse de toute l’Allemagne.
Hegel a une grande influence.
Il est une star intellectuelle.
Un jour, il apprend qu’un de ses élèves
est emprisonné pour raison politique.
Les amis du détenu persuadent Hegel que son
élève est innocent.
Alors le professeur participe à une expédition
avec eux.
Ils passent en bateau, à minuit, sous la
fenêtre de la cellule du détenu, et ils
parlent avec lui.
La conversation se fait en latin — comme
ça, les gardiens ne comprennent rien.
Cette visite est clairement illégale.
Il n’est pas impossible que des sentinelles
découvrent le bateau et que les visiteurs
se fassent tirer dessus.
Pourquoi Hegel prend-il ce risque ?
Parce qu’il est un militant libéral.
Et dans l’Allemagne de l’époque, les
libéraux, ce sont les opposants politiques,
ceux qui, sur le modèle de la Révolution
française, veulent la fin de l’absolutisme
politique.
Être libéral, ça veut dire vouloir que
le pouvoir politique soit LÉGITIME et LIMITÉ.
Une formule rendue célèbre par un article
de Hegel dit qu’il ne concède au roi que
le rôle de « mettre le point sur le i ».
Après, Hegel est un militant libéral TRÈS
PRUDENT.
Il est si prudent qu’il y a plusieurs théories
sur son engagement politique.
Ceux qui ne croient pas à la sincérité
de son libéralisme pensent qu’il est un
agent des autorités, presque un INFILTRÉ
qui fait revenir les partisans des idées
nouvelles sur le droit chemin.
Mais les faits indiquent que l’engagement
libéral de Hegel est sincère.
Il est admis dans les cercles des opposants
politiques.
Il soutient les associations d’étudiants
persécutés par le pouvoir, et il fourre
son nez dans de nombreuses affaires policières
et judiciaires.
Et comme le montre l’expédition en bateau,
il rend même visite à des détenus politiques.
Hegel prend de véritables risques, parce
que d’autres finissent en prison pour moins
que ça.
S’il peut se le permettre, c’est parce
qu’il a de puissants protecteurs au sein
des élites.
En fait, une partie de l’élite allemande
de l’époque déteste Hegel, mais une autre
partie est fan de lui
— donc tant qu’il a des fans dans l’élite,
il peut prendre des risques.
MAIS malgré tout, il reste très prudent.
Il sait qu’il est surveillé ; que les autorités
lisent ses textes et ouvrent son courrier.
Mais ce n’est pas nouveau pour Hegel.
Il évolue dans le secret depuis le début
de sa vingtaine.
À l’époque, les autorités sont effrayées
par les événements de la Révolution française,
donc elles traquent la moindre manifestation
d’opposition.
Comme le jeune Hegel souhaite, lui, que la
Révolution s’étende à l’Allemagne,
il écrit en langage codé dans ses lettres
et il pratique un double langage.
Par exemple, il peut écrire qu’il soutient
les autorités d’une manière dont il sait
que le destinataire de la lettre comprendra
qu’il veut dire l’inverse.
Ça ne fait pas de Hegel un révolutionnaire,
mais il prend quand même de véritables risques.
Et il en prendra en fait toute sa vie adulte.
Il est donc faux de dire, comme Engels, que
Hegel est le philosophe officiel de la Prusse.
Hegel n’est ni le philosophe du pouvoir
ni un pur esprit.
Au contraire, il y a déjà chez lui un peu
de son disciple le plus célèbre qui, lui,
abandonnera totalement la prudence du maître.
« Malgré le malaise que je ressentais et
le fait je ne pouvais vraiment pas comprendre
ce qu'il disait, j'étais totalement captivé.
»
C’est le témoignage d’un étudiant de
Hegel à Heidelberg.
Cet étudiant sera un de ses plus fidèles
disciples, et il deviendra même un de ses
éditeurs.
Donc vous vous rendez compte : l’étudiant
dit « je ne comprends rien, MAIS ça me fascine
» !
Et il n’est pas le seul.
En seulement 2 ans de cours à l’Université
de Heidelberg, Hegel passe de 5 à 70 élèves.
Comment l’expliquer ?
Eh bien c’est que la réputation de Hegel
comme philosophe s’explique en bonne partie
par la puissance de ce que les psychologues
appellent la « preuve sociale ».
Ce concept psychologique signifie qu’un
individu a tendance à penser ou à agir comme
les autres individus.
Autrement dit, nous déterminons ce qui est
bien en observant ce que les autres pensent
être bien.
Comment un étudiant peut-il être fasciné
par un discours qu’il ne comprend pas ?
Parce que beaucoup de gens, dans les cercles
académiques allemands de l’époque, pensent
que Hegel est un grand philosophe qui expose
des idées neuves et profondes.
Je pense que c’est CE phénomène psychologique
qui est à l’œuvre parce que l’obscurité
du discours de Hegel a d’abord été un
handicap.
Son obscurité, c’est une raison qui revient
à plusieurs reprises lorsqu’on lui refuse
un poste à l’université.
Comment expliquer que Hegel soit si difficile
à comprendre ?
C’est peut-être tout d’abord un défaut
naturel, car ses profs lui reprochaient déjà
son manque d’éloquence.
Ensuite, les partisans de Hegel disent que
ses idées sont si originales et si profondes
qu’il est impossible de les exprimer de
manière intelligible.
Mouais… c’est bien commode comme justification
ça.
Et puis comme le discours est inintelligible,
on ne peut même pas vérifier que les idées
de Hegel sont vraiment originales et profondes
!
Mais à l’époque de Hegel, c’est un peu
une mode.
Depuis le succès de Kant, les philosophes
considèrent que le manque de clarté du discours
est presque la mesure de la maîtrise philosophique.
Une autre explication possible, c’est que
l’obscurité peut rendre le discours fascinant.
On a l’impression qu’il recèle une vérité
cachée ;
que nous, les initiés qui faisons l’effort
de déchiffrer Hegel, sommes les seuls à
découvrir un secret inestimable.
Une autre explication qui me paraît également
crédible, c’est que l’obscurité permet
à Hegel d’embrouilller les censeurs.
Ils ne peuvent rien lui reprocher, puisqu’ils
ne comprennent rien !
Et puis de manière pragmatique, les censeurs
estiment que des livres aussi incompréhensibles
ne risquent pas de troubler les autorités.
Enfin, une autre explication — mais plus
controversée — est que l’obscurité permet
aussi à Hegel de dissimuler les faiblesses
de sa pensée.
En effet, Hegel écrit vite, et il a tendance
à pas mal retoucher ses textes, un peu comme
on colmate des fissures dans un mur de briques.
Je penche personnellement pour cette dernière
explication parce que même les spécialistes
de Hegel qui se chargent de « traduire » sa
pensée en langage intelligible ne sont pas
d’accord entre eux !
Dans La société ouverte et ses ennemis,
Karl Popper estime que Hegel a en fait bluffé
pour acquérir une large audience et une notoriété.
« Hegel, écrit Popper, est un écrivain
dont le style indigeste a découragé jusqu’à
ses plus ardents apologistes [...] Hegel se
moque de ses lecteurs.
»
Nous sommes en 1831.
L’épidémie de choléra décline à Berlin,
même si elle fait encore des victimes.
Après avoir été confinés, les gens reprennent
peu à peu une vie normale.
La famille Hegel est revenue à Berlin après
s’être réfugiée à la campagne.
Hegel reprend ses cours, et apparemment il
va bien.
Mais un dimanche matin, il souffre de malaises.
Alors on annule les rendez-vous prévus et
on fait venir les médecins.
Ils estiment d’abord que ce n’est pas
le choléra et ils sont optimistes.
Puis ils changent d’avis : si si, c’est
bien le choléra — et ils prescrivent des
médicaments.
Hegel décède deux jours plus tard dans la
nuit.
Officiellement, il est mort d’un choléra
« sans symptômes extérieurs ».
« Sans symptômes extérieurs » ?
Madame Hegel n’est pas convaincue par le
diagnostic.
Elle sent qu’il y a un loup.
Pourquoi veut-on que le grand philosophe soit
mort du choléra ?
Ce diagnostic permet aux autorités d’éviter
de potentiels troubles.
En effet, elles craignent que les obsèques
de Hegel servent de tribunes aux opposants
de la monarchie prussienne.
Mais grâce au diagnostic, les autorités
ont un prétexte sanitaire pour interdire
des obsèques normales.
Cependant, la veuve de Hegel ne l’entend
pas de cette oreille.
Elle se bat pour imposer les obsèques que
mérite son mari — et elle les obtient.
Le déroulement montre que les craintes des
autorités étaient fondées.
Une immense foule se presse aux obsèques.
L’affluence exceptionnelle des étudiants,
en particulier, est une manifestation d’opposition
au roi et au gouvernement.
En revanche, aucun membre du gouvernement
ni même de la cour n’est présent.
C’est que le vent avait tourné pour Hegel
ces dernières années.
Ses protecteurs disparaissaient les uns après
les autres,
et la partie de l’élite allemande qu’il
dérangeait était de plus en plus puissante.
Et puis les disciples de Hegel n’ont pas
sa prudence :
ils franchissent allègrement les limites
qu’il avait lui-même refusé de franchir.
La position du maître était fragile.
Ses ennemis s’apprêtaient à l’abattre
définitivement.
La dernière manifestation de la prudence
de Hegel, c’est donc peut-être d’être
mort à temps.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre.
Ce travail est vraiment formidable et passionnant.
»
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable.
J'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas, c'est
un vrai travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui ai une mémoire essentiellement auditive.
Le choix des thèmes et des chapitres est
pertinent et je trouve que tu as trouvé la
dose d'approfondissement parfaite ; à la
fois précis mais sans fioritures ! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme.
Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous bénéficiez
d'une garantie résultats : une fois que vous
aurez terminé le programme, je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous n’avez
pas acquis une solide culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.